the report that KIA stammer wants to
stop all new oil and gas exploration is
that true
Well what we'll be doing in our coming
weeks is outlining how we want to invest
in the green jobs of the future to bring
bills down to create a more sustainable
energy Supply we'll be outlining that in
a significant mission in the in the
coming weeks and we'll be announcing
more details then but we know we've got
to move to more renewable sources of
energy it's the it's it's important for
our climate change commitments but it's
also the way in which we can bring
energy bills down for consumers okay
that's interesting sounds very much like
a a yes Mr Ashworth um and if you do
stop all new oil and gas expiration with
the Old Fields being shut down
where does that leave your celebrated
windfall tax uh number one and number
two does not mean that you're going to
ask Britain to rely in the transition to
Net Zero next 30 years or so on supplies
from other sources for example Qatar
perhaps even Russia again
uh no this isn't about shutting down uh
what's going on at the moment we will
manage those sustainably we do think of
windfall tax can be applied they're not
inexhaustible if you stop all new
exploration you are going to have to
fill the Gap from somewhere and it won't
all come from wind we know that that the
the the the sums have been done so where
is it going to come first character it's
a mischaracterization to say our
policies all from win we think we need
to invest in yes we do need to invest in
Wind we need to invest in Tidal we need
to invest in nuclear we need more
sustainable sources of energy Supply in
order to bring bills down for consumers
and actually create jobs in this green
transition there are hundreds of
thousands of jobs that will come online
from a transition to low carbon
Industries and Technology it's not just
directly in the uh energy and the energy
sector but Associated jobs in
manufacturing in design and Engineering
we should be a world leader in this and
one of the things that I want to do in
the way in which I reform welfare reform
the job centers is prepare our Workforce
for the next wave of jobs which is
coming the next sets of opportunities so
that we are ready for these high skill
jobs of the future
all right let let's talk about the first
term uh in your title which is work uh
as you say jobs and let's talk about
who's going to fill those jobs when
we've still got a million vacancies
um legal migration
uh the labor home former labor Home
Secretary uh Alan Johnson reminded
everybody yesterday that the present
point system was introduced by labor
um you weren't there at time but do you
think that the then labor government
um of Tony Blair
foresaw that it would lead to the
highest net immigration figure in
history
well that that high figure that we're
discussing is on the conservatives watch
and they gave us from the system that
you introduced let's let's not blame the
Tories for everything it was your system
well well by the way I wasn't an MP then
and this government has been in power
for 13 years so I'm sorry that I'm going
to focus on the 13 years of this
government and not something that was
happening when I was at school in
University look the immigration system
we want to see migration lower than it
is but immigration is in many ways a
reflection of your health of the labor
market and when you've got a million
people unemployed today and a million
vacancies when you've got 700 000 young
people neither in work or training or
education and when you've got hundreds
of thousands of over 50s and people who
are currently signed off sick but say
they would want to work if given the
right support then I believe we should
be Skilling people investing in people's
trading fixing the red tape and
bureaucracy in the apprenticeship Levy
but also fixing the way our welfare
system works and our job sensors work to
give people the skills and opportunities
to move into work ministers cannot even
tell you how many of that 1.3 million
people unemployed are non-benefits are
actually on a training program they
don't even collect that data I think
that is utterly hopeless when we know
that firms are trying to fill vacancies
in this country today all right you you
your party wants to be in government so
let's if we were made just talk about
you rather than uh do a critique of the
the current government
um you have advanced a policy I
understand this week of restricting
employers right to bring workers from
abroad uh putting in new hurdles there
and regulating pain in order to force
them uh to train British workers is this
a return to Gordon Brown's Mantra of
British jobs for British workers
now what this is is about saying to
firms we you should be investing in the
workforce so you've got all the
potential future workers by investing in
their skills and retraining
opportunities rather than pulling the
lever of going straight to International
Recruitment and undercutting the wages
by cutting those wages by 20 we don't
think that that's fair but as I say when
you how are you going to force them to
do that
well well we would actually this is
about the uh these are the rules
associated with who are on the uh the
the shortage uh occupations list so we
would enforce that these are this is
about government statutory regulatory
rules so we would enforce that but the
second thing is that we would do which a
labor government would do is we're going
to reform the way our job centers work
we're actually going to give more power
and responsibilities to local areas so
they can redesign the types of training
that is on offer to the moment all you
get if you go to a job center all you
get is essentially CV writing training
well when you've got AI coming along
which is going to write the CVS for you
you really need a new way in which you
can train and retrain people and upskill
people for the future so that's one of
the things we're going to do and here's
a very significant welfare reform that I
am proposing if you're off work for
reasons of sickness at the moment and
you've been through something called the
work capability assessment that acts as
a disincentive for you trying to return
to work so I will give people an into
work guarantee by reforming those
assessments so reforms to look to the
apprenticeship Levy reforms the way job
centers train people reforms the benefit
system reforms to the immigration system
that's a substantial package of Reform
to get more people back to work and more
people into the jobs of the future thank
you well let's dig into that because you
talked to this morning about exactly
that program of work one of the things I
noticed in your announcement you talked
about a tailored job support is that um
code for 14 people back to work
well the moment people who are on it's
now called Universal Credit as you know
Trevor but essentially the old job
Seekers related benefit there are
conditions attached there are conditions
attached to people claiming those
benefits and we will keep those
conditions we will want people to move
into jobs but we'll also offer people
decent training and reskilling
opportunities at the moment you get sent
to us but I don't think that's good
enough but but they're offered that
already and I I'm interested in this
because uh you know it's what
governments do they are honest with the
people and it seems to me that what you
are saying is that you are going to be
tougher on people who are currently on
as you say Universal Bennett or sickness
benefit is that correct
well I I I mean the word tougher has
brings me all kinds of connotations I'm
going to have a fair system well it's
just a fair system giving people giving
people the support and the help that
they need to move into work let me give
you an absolutely astonishing statistic
older people out of work and sick and
disabled people out of work even though
many of them say they want help to move
into work only one in ten are getting
any support to move into a job I think
that is absolutely extraordinary and is
writing off
huge numbers of people who've got huge
who've got huge potential to contribute
and who say they actually want to work
so we've got to reform this job center
system and we've got to reform the way
in which our benefit assessment system
work they are some of the Practical
reforms I am putting forward which will
help people get back to work because I
don't think it's acceptable look
actually the government actually copied
some of my reforms they said they're
going to do that but actually they're
not going to do them for years and years
they're relying on International
recruitment all right Jonathan thank you
very much for your time this morning